Nos dicen que un almacén de electrónica
envía televisiones y reproductores de DVD
de manera combinada
a distribuidores de todo el país.
El peso de 3 televisiones
y 5 reproductores DVD es de 62.5 libras
y el peso de 3 televisiones y 2 reproductores DVD es
52 libras, nos están dando dos combinaciones.
Construye un sistema de ecuaciones
que represente esta situación.
Entonces resuélvelo para encontrar cuánto
pesa cada televisión y reproductor DVD.
Aquí nos están dando dos pedazos de información,
los cuales podemos transformar en ecuaciones,
el primero es que el peso de 3 televisiones
y 5 reproductores DVD es 62.5 libras,
también nos dicen que el peso de 3 televisiones y
2 reproductores DVD es 52 libras.
Podemos transformar esto directamente en ecuaciones,
si hacemos "t" el peso de una televisión
y "d" el peso de un reproductor DVD,
este enunciado de aquí establece
que 3 veces el número de televisiones
o más bien 3 por el peso de las televisiones
más 5 veces el peso de los reproductores DVD
es igual a 62.5 libras,
eso es exactamente lo que dice
este primer enunciado.
El segundo enunciado el peso de 3 televisiones
y 2 reproductores DVD
lo podemos escribir como 3 televisiones
más 2 reproductores DVD,
el peso de 3 televisiones más el peso
de 2 reproductores DVD es igual a 52 libras.
Bien, ya tenemos un sistema de ecuaciones,
ya cumplimos con la primera parte,
elabora un sistema de ecuaciones,
ahora tenemos que resolverlo.
Al ver nuestro sistema de ecuaciones
y que tenemos dos términos iguales,
tenemos "3t" aquí y "3t" acá, podemos entonces multiplicar una de estas ecuaciones
por un factor adecuado,
de tal manera que cuando sumemos esta ecuación
con la ecuación que tenemos arriba,
los términos en "t" se van a cancelar.
Eso es lo que vamos a hacer y podemos hacer
esto de sumar ecuaciones
pues como vimos cuando revisamos
los fundamentos de álgebra,
cuando tú haces algo de un lado de la ecuación,
lo tienes que hacer del otro lado de la ecuación,
si sumas 3 de un lado,
tienes que sumar 3 del otro lado,
así es que si agrego esto
al lado izquierdo de esta ecuación,
si agrego esto en azul al lado izquierdo de la ecuación
en rojo, puedo sumar 52 al lado derecho,
pues esto es lo mismo,
el lado izquierdo es igual a 52, es decir,
estamos sumando 52 también al lado izquierdo,
solo que escrito de otra manera.
Ahora, antes de hacer esa suma, lo que tengo
que hacer es multiplicar esta segunda ecuación por -1,
así es que al multiplicar por -1
tenemos "-3t" más "-2d" igual a -52,
no he cambiado la información de la ecuación
solo la he multiplicado por -1.
He hecho eso pues ahora que sume las ecuaciones
estos términos "3t" se van a cancelar.
Hagamos eso, sumemos estas ecuaciones.
Y recuerda, lo único que estamos haciendo
es sumar lo mismo a ambos lados de la ecuación,
estamos sumando ambos lados -52, ahora que
hemos multiplicado la segunda ecuación por 1,
pues -3 más "-2d" es exactamente igual
a -52, hagamos la suma entonces,
"3t" más "-3t" se cancelan, para eso estamos haciendo
esto, ahora "5d" más "-2d"
ó "5d" menos "2d" es igual a "3d"
y del lado derecho nos queda, 62.5 más -52
ó 62.5 menos 52 esto es igual a 10.5...
10.5.
Ahora, dividiendo entre 3 ambos lados de la
ecuación, ¿qué nos queda?
Del lado izquierdo nos queda "d" y del lado
derecho nos queda 10.5 entre 3, calculémoslo,
vamos a dividir entre 3, 10.5,
10 entre 3 es igual a 3, 3 por 3 = 9, lo restamos,
10 menos 9 es 1, bajamos el 5, por supuesto tenemos
el punto decimal y 15 entre 3 nos da 5,
5 por 3 = 15, lo restamos, 15 menos 15 es igual
a 0, así es que esto nos resulta que "d"
el peso de cada reproductor DVD
es de 3.5 libras.
Vamos ahora a sustituir este valor de "d"
en una de las ecuaciones que tenemos arriba
para encontrar el peso de cada televisión.
Usemos la ecuación de arriba.
Tenemos que 3 por "t" más 5 por el valor de 3.5,
el valor de "d" que acabamos de encontrar,
5 por 3.5, recuerda, estamos buscando valores
que cumplan con ambas ecuaciones,
así es que esto va a ser igual a 62.5.
¿Qué tenemos ahora?
"3t" más 5 por 3.5, 5 por 3 es 15,
5 por .5 es 2.5, 15 más 2.5 es 17.5
y esto es igual a 62.5.
Vamos ahora a restar 17.5
a ambos lados de la ecuación...
restamos 17.5 a ambos lados de la ecuación,
lo cual nos queda "3t" del lado izquierdo,
estos términos se cancelan, queríamos dejar
a "3t" sola del lado izquierdo,
por lo que "3t" va a ser igual a...
veamos...
62.5 menos 17.5, tan solo queda 62 menos 17,
veamos, 62 menos 7 es igual a 55,
si restamos otros 10 nos queda 45,
así es que esto va a ser igual a 45,
dividiendo ahora entre 3 ambos lados de la ecuación, nos resulta que "t" es igual a 15,
hemos resulto nuestro sistema,
encontramos que el peso
del reproductor DVD es 3.5 libras,
mientras que el peso de la televisión es de 15 libras, hemos concluido.